التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث حملت الساعات الاخيره اكثر
من تطور ميداني قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه شنت هجوما بسته عشره طائره
مسيره وسته صواريخ في الساعات الماضيه
معلنا تدمير عشر مسيرات واربعه صواريخ
من تاثر محطه النوويه باستهداف سد كخوفك
قالت وكاله طاقه الذريه الاوكرانيه ان
الوضع في محطه نوويه مازال مستقرا شرقا
وفي مقاطعه على وجه الدقه قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه انها قصفت موقعا
للقوات الشيشانيه وقتلت عددا من افرادها
على الجانب الروسي اصيب شخصان نتيجه سقوط
مسيره في مدينه فرونيش جنوب غربي البلاد
عدنان ما الذي نتج عن استهداف كياف خلال
الساعات الماضيه بمسيرات وصواريخ
نعم جليل جلال كيف وغيرها نتحدث عن موجه
هجوم كبيره وواسعه تحدثت عنها القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه على كياب وعلى عموم
الاراضي الاوكرانيه حاله تعهد جوي كانت
كبيره بالامس يتم الحديث عن نحو سته عشر
مسيره من نوع ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شاهد
يتم الحديث عن سته صواريخ كروز ويتم الحدث
ايضا عن صاروخين كاليبر هذه الصواريخ
استهدفت مناطق عده كييف كما قلنا ومقاطعات
اخرى في البلاد بشكل اساسي تم تاكيد اسقاط
اربعه صواريخ كروز وعشر مسيرات من نوع
شاهد كانت تستهدف بحسب القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه مناطق سكنيه وبنى تحتيه
اوكرانيه لكن يتم التاكيد بان بعض هذه
الصواريخ والمسيرات نجحت بالوصول الى
اهداف تؤكد مجددا القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها كانت مناطق سكنيه وبنن
تحتيه بشكل اساسي جلال هذا الحديث عن
القصف يمتد ايضا حتى الى خرسون التي تشهد
ذلك الغمر نتيجه تدمير سد كخوفكا وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تؤكد ان المناطق هناك
تشهد قصفا روسيا بما في ذلك مناطق الاجلاء
وقد نشرت بالامس صورا لهذه الاستهدافات
الروسيه بالحديث عن عمليات الاجلاء
المستمره هناك جلال يتم الحديث عن عمليات
مستمره حتى الان وصلت الى سقف نحو ثلاثه
الاف اوكراني تم اجلاؤهم ما زال هناك
الكثير العدد الاجمالي الذي تم الحديث عنه
على الضفه اليمنى هو 17 الفا لكن الجديد
فيما يتعلق ايضا بعمليات الاجلاء جلال هو
اعلان وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه بالامس
اتفاقا مع الامم المتحده على ان تنفذ
الامم المتحده عمليات اجلاء للمنتظرين على
الضفه اليسرى اي المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه على ان تقدم كيف ضمانات
بعدم اطلاق او القصف هناك وقد تعهدت كيف
بحسب الخارجيه ويتم الحديث عن ان الموافق
المرتقبه الان هي من من الجانب الروسي
هناك بشكل اساسي الان يتم الحديث عن حساب
المياه كما تحدثتم جلال الى نحو خمسه خمسه
امتار فاصله ثلاثه هذا الانحسار هو فيه
جانبان ايجابي لانه سيسهل عمليه اخراج
الناس المعزولين في مساكنهم سلبي نظرا
للتحذيرات التي طالت من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه من الالغام والمتفجرات التي
جرفت مع انتشار مياه الغمر بعد التفجير سد
كخوف كجلال شكرا لكما عدنان
في جورل